attention pour la poussière en baie du
renard ouanna dumoulin walla d'humour
[Musique]
au village de puyloubier 70 km de
marseille
cernée par les vignes au pied de la
montagne sainte-victoire cher aux
peintres cézanne une maison de repos pas
tout à fait comme les autres
la plupart des pensionnaires ici sont
étrangers tous sont d'anciens soldats de
l'armée française qui ont servi dans la
plus prestigieuse de ses unités la
légion étrangère
créée au siècle dernier pour protéger
lempire la légion étrangère fut de tous
les combats de toutes les guerres
ses faits d'armes sont entrés dans
l'histoire sébastopol narvik dien bien
phu kolwezi payant un lourd tribut
trente cinq mille morts en 170 ans en
1863 le siège de camerone au mexique
seule exigence des quatre survivants
soigner les blessés
la légion n'abandonne jamais les siens
une légende est née ce jour là la devise
région c'est legio patria nostra
donc c'est la famille donc la famille
quand on a une famille dans le civil les
enfants ils ont été élevés par les
parents et puis quand les parents ils
sont plus capables de subvenir tout seul
c'est les enfants qui s'occupe des
parents ben oui c'est un petit peu la
même chose on en fait des légionnaires
ont fait une carrière
ensuite eh ben ils sont à la retraite et
bars en eau qu on a pas le droit d
abonnés on s'en occupe jusqu'à la mort
puisque puisqu'au derniers jours et dont
les emmène fraternité que l'on ne
retrouve donc une autre armée au monde
derrière ses grilles ils sont
aujourd'hui 140 le seul à ne pas être
encore à la retraite
cet homme il est le directeur des lieux
après 31 ans de service une mission de
plus le fait que ce que je fais le matin
mais tellement voilà c'est mon du matin
tout le monde le bordel tous les deux
ont fait le petit tour du la maison et
ça nous permet de prendre la température
et puis de régler les problèmes qui sont
en cours pour la journée coin des petits
trucs de la journée ici l'oise yves
tenais pas au programme
chacun peut avoir une activité un petit
boulot qu'ils occupent et qui sert à
améliorer l'ordinaire pour vous au
moment d'être ici non c'est un immense
honneur d'abord premièrement avoir
l'honneur de s'occuper de mes anciens
ceux qui ont donné bien
des fois des mêmes une partie de leur
vie une partie de leur temps être parce
qu'il y en a qui sont encore qui ont
encore les stigmates dans l'ordre dans
leur chair des combat qu'ils ont mené le
temps qu'ils étendent active la légion
il l'a servi pendant 20 ans pour sa
retraite il a choisi de revenir au
milieu de ses frères d'armes
arrivé en 1976 gunther l'allemand a
retrouvé ici des habitudes de soldats
mais comme on sale de manger c'est là
bas mon lieu de travail
et là bas comme chaque matin gunther
rejoint son poste
en fait l'atelier de reliure en échange
d'un peu d'argent qui lui sert à acheter
des cigarettes
il retape quelques vieux livres
militaire activités que gunter a préféré
à la céramique ou à la taille des vignes
[Musique]
nous avons la chance de servir dans le
mémoire gym ans il y à 25 ans nous
étions ensemble comme sous-officier et
c'est quelqu'un qui était très sportif
rivaux avec lui comme avec les autres
je suis directeur lui c'est un paul
seuls pensionnaires mais l'amitié n'est
restée égale à elle-même avec gunter bon
courage à tout à l'heure
l'histoire de ce soldat commence dans
l'allemagne des années noires
né en 1934 gunther est encore un enfant
quand son père est tué à stalingrad à 11
ans bazooka sur l'épaule il tente de
faire face aux blindés américains
l'allemagne et des fêtes dans
l'après-guerre la légion étrangère ouvre
ses portes à l'ennemi d'hier
gunther il passera 20 ans de sa vie
quand vous avez quitté votre e dan
france et vous êtes 20 ans absent et
vous retourner là bas les amis
le copain copine comme on dit non et se
marier et sont dispersés dans tout le
monde
ils avaient plus là vous rentrez chez
vous comme étrangers pour un crime ou
comme étrangers comme j'étais assez âgés
y avait plus de 100 me en allemand alors
il me donnait tout le moyenne cela veut
dire logement logement nourriture
ambiance familiale de ces guerres et de
ses voyages avec la légion gunther n'a
ramené que souvenir ni femme ni enfant
son quotidien désormais rythmée par de
fréquents allers-retours au comptoir du
foyer tous les pensionnaires s'y
retrouve quelques uns veulent rester
anonymes
si c'est possible ne filme pas dedans tu
veux pas certains traitent n'aimais pas
ça
le bar un lieu de rendez vous pour ces
guerriers sur le retour l'endroit où
aujourd'hui parfois gunther se laisse
aller à quelques souvenirs
arrosez d'amertume 10 juin des négoces a
été formé à les creux au lait cru mais
on ne s'est formée déjà le matin tu
rentres ali là ils me cassent la
lyonnaise
emma prix tout la jeune âge
l'histoire tragique du sergent-chef tour
bergues n'est pas la seule dans la
légion beaucoup d'histoires se
ressemblent elles et sont souvent
dramatiques chèque chaque cas et
personnel soit c'est un échec
sentimental soient cédés des systèmes
politiques qui leur convenait pas soit
scellé des problèmes familiaux soit
c'est des problèmes sociaux donc chacun
parcours différents chacun à sa
reproduction
mais à partir de l'instant où il est
rentré à la légion étrangère il a
intégré une famille il intègre une
famille et puis cette famille là bas il
la quittera le jour où il partira
il la quittera jamais jamais de la
débâcle allemande à la chute de diên
biên phu en 1954 45000 allemands ont
rejoint les rangs de la légion beaucoup
sont morts pour la france
quelques survivants en encore
puis double parmi eux présents ici
depuis trente ans un vieux monsieur de
80 non c'est moi le responsable du
vestiaire je choisis les vêtements je
les fais réparer éventuellement g roupe
je vais répartis entre les quatre murs
de cette petite pièce la dernière
mission du commandant sigfried freitag
héros de la louve av
pendant la deuxième guerre mondiale ce
brillant pilote de combat dirigeait une
escadrille de meschers smit 102
victoires à son actif deux fois battu il
a reçu la plus prestigieuse des
décorations du régime nazi
la croix de guerre est-ce que vous avez
été prisonnier es ce que vous avez été
prisonnier après la guerre oui c'était
fin avril dans les alpes bavaroises
nous nous sommes repliés
on venait de munich et on s'est replié
dans les montagnes c'est là que les
américains nous ont rattrapés après les
avoir couverts de gloire l'allemagne
vaincue fait de ses pilotes
les boucs émissaires de la défaite une
accusation au goût amer pour que vous
n'êtes pas rester en allemagne
je voulais déjà expliqué mon travail ne
me plaisait pas il a légion chercher du
monde eh bien je me suis engagé à la
légion je vais plus de familles en
allemagne résultat 18 ans de légion pour
freitag
et comme pour gunther le soldat une même
décision c'est à cette armée là qu'on
restera fidèle jusqu'au bout du jury
d'autres avaient rester légionnaires
même après sa mort
la récompense du sang versé
vous êtes content de terminer vos jours
ici dans cette
c'est ça qu'est née choisissait ga des
quais je veux être pas encore mais un
jour intérêts au carré les jours avec
deux ans deviendra de l'autre côté du
village un cimetière le carré légion
aujourd'hui c'est l'anniversaire de la
bataille de camerone mes délégations
officiers sous-officiers et militaires
du rang donc c'est là à partir d'ici
jusque là j'ai le col
ça colle qui parle la ceinture
le souvenir de la résistance héroïque
des légionnaires de cameron est célébrée
chaque année et pour les pensionnaires
les plus valides de l'institution pas
question de rater les cérémonies au
cimetière le respect aux anciens c'est
un autre des piliers de la légion on
fait la célébration de cameron donc on
va rendre hommage aux anciens
donc si vous voyez quelqu'un de fatigué
ou quelqu'un qui se conduit mal il faut
pas laisser tomber
il faut attendre de solidarité ou le
prend on va le coucher comme on fait à
l'aller lyon on avant d'autres personnes
haifa qu'il y ait mal bassin j'en rigole
pas mal d'autres mines ahmed
c'est important d'aider les anciens
bien sûr c'est important on est payé
pour ça
sinon mais c'est surtout le coeur qui
parle
c'est sur twitter parce que bon puisque
l'huile et il a même origine que moi
en ce moment on est à dire je vais le le
problème c'est qu'on attend le même club
à flot de football créée à rome
aps encore à pêche chinois telle liu et
jean-pierre mortelette l'aide soignant
de l'infirmerie après avoir essayé tous
les postes c'est sa dernière affectation
après une courte carrière d'officier de
police jean pierre s'engage à 28 ans
dans la légion
à sa sortie il commet une grosse bêtise
comme il dit qui le conduit aux assises
ne pas vous trichez j'étais dix ans en
prison et c'est un ancien légionnaire
qui m'envoyait de l'argent tu m'en voyez
ce que j'avais besoin pendant vos années
de crise mais il a su que j'étais en
prison est pendant sur les dix ans j'ai
fait six ans et demi pendant six ans et
demi mile et en 1994 jean pierre
mortelette libéré mais à 47 ans sans
ressources ni famille une seule issue
s'offrent à lui retourner à la légion
qui ne lui demande pas de comptes cool
et quand je dis le prison institution d
aval il m'a acceptée telle que gt
commençait à les joueurs on va donner un
travail non occupation des loisirs on
m'a écouté si je peux aller voir le
comment je vais devoir la du hachage de
le voir à son bourreau rim écoute si
j'ai besoin d'un fonds relais bien sûr
ça c'est normal mais sinon si je n'ai
pas eu l'institution là c'était je passe
ce ne serait même pas je serai
certainement la gare saint-charles où
quelques parades faire la marche
à puyloubier les pensionnaires ont à
leur disposition un foyer tous sans
exception le fréquentent
à son arrivée jean pierre mortelette
venait souvent tutoyé sa solitude entre
parties de cartes ou au jeu de d il est
vrai qu on y boit pour pas cher
6 francs la canette de bière
un tarif qui a poussé jean pierre
mortelette à tous les excès vous savez
si on est dans une société où il ya que
des envies d'ailleurs
eh ben on voit un cours à coups et puis
on a recommencé tu recommences gelé
vraiment mal
puis bon je veux un docteur à pied 4 il
m'a librement un traitement comme chez
nous on a plus craints limonade
si la discipline reste la même les
occupations de chacun n'ont rien de
militaire
le travail n'est bien sûr pas
obligatoire et chaque pensionnaire est
libre d'occuper son emploi du temps
comme il le veut
[Musique]
alex dupuy à 50 ans de son séjour en
guyane le caporal a gardé la passion de
la nature et des animaux
et quand il ne travaille pas à la vigne
il s'adonne à son passe temps favori
[Musique]
on a été au tir à l'arc ce matin ça fait
un carton au tap a fait un carton
j'ai fait un beau tir ouais pas trop
fatigué d'hier tous les week-ends ils
ont des loisirs alors y'en a qui vont
jouer aux boules y en a d'autres qui
jouent aux cartes y en a d'autres qui
font du tir à l'arc
elle a d'autres qui marchent qui vont se
promener donc les gens ils sont même si
l'on nous un travail même s'ils sont
fatigués à la fin de la semaine
là-bas le week-end il est il occupa une
activité ils restent pas enfermés
cloîtrée dans les chambres alors lui
vous le croisez souvent on le croit
souvent puis c'est râpé un personnage
pittoresque de l'institution comme tous
les vendredis l'heure du rapport
incontournable dans la légion
l'occasion aussi pour le commandant
toqués de faire le point at on la nomme
aux cds d'accord
un peu à ce sport
bon je te passera par an demandent de
celle des cinq jours du 4 mai au 9 mai
inclus d'accord tu restes sur zone vers
mon ami tu vois je la famille qui vient
te voir personne bon je tiens j'en
profite parce que c'est vrai que je te
vois tous les jours ici c'est dans un
cadre un peu plus formel et je tiens à
te féliciter parce que je suis très
content de toi tout le boulot tu fais
actuellement
ce remarquable au patron de le chef du
service général il est on a besoin il
est satisfait de ton boulot quand tu
fais des conneries je n'hésite pas à
violer mais aussi quand il fait bien il
faut bien que je me souviens également
hockey ahl et arnaud gauze
oui entre
[Musique]
talus perdu pu aller avec ça c'est toi
alors raconte moi un peu parce que c'est
vrai que c'est la suite de thé de ton
équipe de tir là un jeu rôle tu as une
belle coupe c'est pour ça que j'ai
demandé à ce que tu me la caisse il
amène avec ses tigres l'atelier oui oui
et voilà c'est ça tu fais partie il est
grand arche et maintenant c'est ce que
tu pourrais lui c'est bien par contre
mon grand ben natan il faut continuer
parce qu'il faut qu'on ouais c'est toi
tu dans ta chambre parce que là tu vois
tu la menace comme toi tu es en vie
je fais une petite étagère ou tu
commences à d aligner les couples a déjà
deux et puis bravo parce que au moins tu
as tu as représenter l'institution tu es
aussi un fanion de l'institution est
possible vichy doit faire c'est bien
aller alex bonne soirée mon gars et
continuer à entraîner un voilà tout à
fait tu vas rose et sa mousse bon c'est
d'autres parutions s'accorder a pas de
problème et dupuis s'est vu profit des
citations ensuite à son résultat au
concours de tir à l'arc
[Musique]
l'indochine la légion est écrit avec son
sens les pages les plus dramatiques de
son histoire
onze mille morts des combats souvent au
corps à corps contre un ennemi déterminé
peu de survivants
leur témoignage est rare dur
moi j'en ai vu tomber de fatigue on a
compassion on veut les aider on prend
son sac il ya là même qui ont pris bon
ça que moi ça m'arrivait aussi
arrive le moment où on n'en peut plus
moi j'ai eu tout le scorbut sa joie j'ai
eu et le paludisme le béribéri le
scorbut la dysenterie amibienne tout ça
m'est tombé dessus en très peu de temps
comme beaucoup là bas on buvait l'eau
des rivières où bon vous dit pas ce
qu'il y avait dans l'eau quand même à ce
jour quelqu'un pour aider l'autre
toujours en richard liés à la légion l'a
toujours appelé max belge
il a passé 22 ans sur le terrain en
indochine en algérie officier de la
légion d'honneur plusieurs fois décoré
il a choisi de consacrer la fin de sa
vie à ses camarades à ceux qui ne se
sont jamais remis de leurs blessures
comme il dit tous les jours deux bouts à
3 heures du matin depuis 20 ans il règne
sur la popote moi vous voyez comment je
me voyais comme jeune bein ses fils
maudit 49,50 savez je ne la guerre
contre les japonais là debout par bing
bout moi je me voyais comme ça et la
réalité
sa durée la première blessure que j'ai
eu après c'était fini je rentre je me
couche ya plus vite que les autres
un autre héros de puyloubier joseph
horvat à dien bien phu il a été le radio
du général bigeard
cet homme de 78 ans aujourd'hui a
toujours été soldat d'abord dans l'armée
hongroise avant d'être enrôlé par les
allemands en 1939
à 27 ans il signe son premier contrat la
légion c'était en 1950 les murs de sa
chambre raconte son passé glorieux mais
les vrais souvenirs
joseph les porte en lui comme un lourd
fardeau vous avez été blessé
combien de fois de faux vol
une fois par minute par le podium d'un
fou on ne fait la cour à korhogo et je
ne peux pas éviter la cour de
baïonnettes de chinois oui mais oui la
mode mais mon nom mai 1954 le début de
la fin pour l' empire colonial français
dien bien phu vient de tomber le 7 mai
grièvement blessé lors des derniers
combats
joseph horvath et évacué par la croix
rouge qu'est ce que vous a apporté la
légion au mont houy
il y avait les trois réponses oui la
gloire
d'accord la souffrance et la
tranquillité oui
bougez plus neigeux trash l'argent les
couples vanessa et la coiffeuse de
l'institution elle a 20 ans elle vient
ici une fois par semaine à ce point
d'activité ça fait longtemps j'étais
libre et va être tes nouvelles boston 16
je sais pas encore mais c'est des amours
serait dur ne pas s'entendre avec ils
sont gentils quand vous arrivez sont
contents quand vous partez ils sont un
peu triste de voir bientôt madame et où
ils sont vraiment très j'ai travaillé
avec des femmes et j'ai préféré arrêter
pour rester quelques légionnaires vous
travaillez avec une centaine d'ong du
phare il se vante pas trop hein et de
disques disent qu'ils ont été
dubout check out et d'arrêter là mais il
s'étale pas sur leur grade sur ce qu'ils
ont fait c'est pas des gens qui se
fanent terrain des numéros de puniet
passer un bon week-end
j'espère que je vienne souffler un bon
coup
saab avait un problème on lance à menton
en cô
présentée 11h carré des anciens la
cérémonie commence la france au nord
c'est étrange est tombé pour elle aucun
des pensionnaires de puyloubier ne veut
manquer cet instant pour tous la date
est sacré à cameron en 1863 60
légionnaires ont résisté 11 heures
durant à 2000 soldats mexicains à la
tombée de la nuit il n'y a que quatre
survivants
chaque année depuis 7 au garde-à-vous
que l'on écoute le récit de la légende
nous nous rendrons si vous me promettez
de relever et de soigner nos blessés
et si vous nous laissez nous charles
lors baïonnette restait menaçante on ne
refuse rien à des sommes qu'on vous
répondre l'officier
[Musique]
il ya beaucoup de pudeur dans cette
maison c'est vrai qu'on en apprend mais
toujours très peu à chaque fois c'est
toujours par bride c'est pas un grand
déballage
c'est toujours une petite briet de la
puis c'est bien comme ça il faut aussi
que
le petit jardin secret
[Musique]